if 2020 couldn't get any worse let me
introduce you to
2036 a world on the brink of war and a
movie featuring anthony mackie's best
performance since he had sex with his
best friend in a video game you wax your
boss
what what outside the wire is netflix's
latest sci-fi action film that asks the
question
can the guy who played euro and greyjoy
play anything but a villain
where are my niece and nephew let's go
further than in this video we'll be
taking a deep dive into the film's
ending and some of those little details
you may have missed
so make sure to like and subscribe
because here we
go violent civil war no this isn't the
attack on the capital last week
this is eastern europe in the year 2036.
lieutenant thomas harp plays a drone
pilot for the us military he's played by
damson idris who also started an episode
of black mirror in the film's very first
scene he must make a life-changing
decision does he go ahead and shoot a
mobile launcher which would kill
two american soldiers or does he do
nothing letting the enemy launcher
potentially kill the entire platoon when
ordered by his superior officer to stand
down
harp disobeys and fires anyway killing
those two men it's a decision that
almost gets harp
court-martialed instead he's deployed
overseas as part of experientum
actoriate or
authority of experience the idea that
only when drone pilots know what it's
like on the ground can they make better
decisions
we see the difference between the
soldiers on the ground and the drone
pilots the soldiers on the ground are
literally fighting for their lives
while the drone pilots are halfway
around the world in nevada sitting in
comfy chairs eating gummy bears
harp is sent to the block where the
gumps are held i got a pig
robotic soldiers who are literally the
worst there are two times in the movie
where there's like a super tense moment
one of which includes hostages and these
robots are just like
[ __ ] it do it live and it makes sense
harp meets captain leo in this block as
we'll find out
leo is robotic he refers to himself as
fourth
generation biotech and it's clear these
two share more differences than just a
robot versus human
they differ in their philosophies leo
finds harp to be emotionless
god damn you a cold [ __ ] harp
says you have to be since emotion leads
to mistakes and
in this line of work you can't afford
those people are stupid
habitual lazy their emotions lead to
mistakes
it's pretty interesting then that it's
the machine who has the opposite view
maybe humans aren't emotional enough
lieutenant leo and harp are tasked with
a covert operation outside the wire the
area outside the demilitarized zone
ukraine has become a hostile war zone in
which russia and the resistance fight
for control with the united states
playing peacekeeper their mission
involves finding viktor koval a warlord
who wants ukraine to become part of
russia
remind you of anyone
over the course of the movie they find
victor is seeking control of nuclear
passcodes to russia's systema perimeter
abandoned cold war bases which still
hold nuclear weapons
if koval could get a hold of these he
plans on nuking the united states
harp doesn't like how leo operates he
doesn't notify command when they find a
koval spy
buys illegal weapons from a resistance
leader and has harp take out his
tracking chip
well at least that's what he tells harp
we'll find out later this isn't a
tracking chip at all it's leo's failsafe
installed in him should he go rogue
and that's exactly what happens to him
about halfway through the movie harp
finds out that he's been manipulated by
leo leo isn't the one in command
he is all this time harp thought he was
the subordinate
so we're partners [ __ ] no
my support for example when they find
the koval spy at the refugee camp their
trail to koval goes cold their orders
are that if the trail goes cold the
operation is to be aborted and they have
to return to base
unless an intel officer like harp has a
hunch an intel officer like yourself can
follow an aborted line and is considered
a hunch if i do it
it's a fault so leo manipulates harp in
order to conduct his master plan
and this involves leo getting harp
involved in acts of insubordination
so his programming no longer needs to
follow harp's orders my backup system
allows me to relinquish the need for
human authority
if said person is exhibiting improper or
impaired judgment
in fact leo specifically requested harp
for this job because of his ability to
exhibit improper and
impaired judgment and with this
fail-safe taken out leo has become a
rogue agent hell-bent on releasing the
nukes on america
but why as sophia the resistance leader
tells harp it's not the u.s that wants
peace
in fact it's the opposite
destabilization in the area is
great for america it boosts the
military-industrial machine and causes
their enemy russia to focus their
efforts on their ukraine instead
of the u.s america benefits from war in
the region but that still doesn't
explain why leo goes rogue
he goes rogue because he believes what
he's doing will save more lives than it
kills
it's ironic because this is the same
utilitarian thinking harp used at the
beginning harp believed that by
sacrificing two people
he'd save the rest of the platoon leo
believes that by killing one million
he'll save a hundred million that's the
man that killed two to save 38. then you
kill a million now
save a hundred million leo believes
these autonomous cyborgs like himself
will only lead to more death and
destruction
so if he can prove to the world they are
faulty i.e able to go rogue and launch
nukes they'll have no choice but to stop
production
you want them to shut the program down
for a long long time they need to
understand that these wars
must end and i
am the face of never ending war harp
goes from an emotionless cold and
calculated drone pilot we see at the
beginning of the film
to the opposite instead of letting leo
get away with his attack he stops him
believing that the greater good isn't
about what saves more lives but
believing that humanity
can become better humans can learn to do
better
that is the greater good leo harp is
able to escape right in the nick of time
as a drone strike takes out the nukes
and don't ask me how that's possible
without completely setting them all off
i'll have to bring neil degrasse tyson
on next time to clear that up with harp
having saved the day he's granted
permission to go back home and be with
his girlfriend and the us military will
probably be like hey we probably
shouldn't make those super soldiers
anymore although the movie is
action-packed with sci-fi elements it's
really a movie about our decisions
emotional versus practical human versus
robotic
if you were in harp shoes would you also
make the same decision
i want you to leave a comment below
thanks for watching everyone please make
sure to like and subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram
at thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
you